Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie
Intro malaisante ...
Aujourd'hui nous sommes sur Zlap.io
On a déjà fait  600 000 000 000 de jeu .io
Mais je vous assure que celui-ci est mieux que ceux d'avant
Et à chaque fois je dis ça, tuez moi !
On va s'appeler... Masse...tock.
On commence direct sur un jeu de mot on est comme ça !
Donc ! Dans zlap.io en gros on contrôle son personnage avec euuuh euh "ZQSD"
Et on bouge la masse avec la souris.
Et le but c'est de tuer les gens avec cette masse
Ah par exemple ... AHHH il nous a eu !
Fils de pute tu as niqué mon intro ...
D'ailleurs lui par exemple, il a une énorme masse, 'faut qu'on l'tue. Regardez.
On va le tuer, on va le tuer ! On va .. Ahh nooon
J'ai pas le droit
Bon, les gars, je suis massetock, ma masse va devenir tock, c'est hyper nul ce que je dis
Ohhh ouiiii
Et la, hop ma masse devient grosse, elle devient énorme.
Elle devient énorme et séche, et la regarder des vidéos de, je ne dirais pas de qui
Ah Putaaiin , mais je vais l'avoir mec c'est pas possible
Ok technique de l’éléphant
♪ Un éléphant qui se balançaient sur une ... ♪
Fantastique ou pas ?
Attends lui il faut que je le tuer hein ?
Oh oui , regarde attends , j'essaie d'esquiver son ...
OOOOOOOOH Il a tellement bien ....
Pi Pa Pa Bo (musique)
Pira Pi... (rire)
YOLO! BITCH
Alleeeeeeeeeeez
Et donc plus elle est grosse plus il va loin aussi hein?
C'est très bizarre
oh xbd1999 c'est presque un 2000 non ?
Et oh mais il sont forts les gens ça suffit j'en ai marre
voila je vais dans une game ou il y a que des nuls
c'est le retour de ... De xxx
c'est retour de Vin Diezel on va tué Vin Diezel
Je peux le mettre dans la miniature
ç’a fera plein de vue
ON A TUE VIN DIEZEL DOUBLE KILL
Ah bah c'est ça être YouTuber, c'est rusé hein
Oh .....
AH HAHA
En fait Je pense que le but sinon tu as l'aise devant toi et ça te protège en fait en vrai
même ça je suis pas foutu de l’illustrer correctement Bordel de merde
Hey ty il est pour nous si on le tue on dit Thank You
THANK YOUU
Oh t'es mort , oh t'es mort
Oui
Putain je suis bon la
Là je suis en bonne lancé mon gars
Faut surtout pas qu'on s’arrête là
Oh WTF ? (rire)
le gars il est trop chaud
OH Putain y en a qui sont énormes mon gars
Tu fais quoi toi tu fais quoi ?
Ah mais noon
Le mec il arrive il se régale quoi je le déteste
Quoi ? Ah bon
improbable , sa c'est l'équivalent a un 360 no scope dans Call of Duty
Andy Allez elle s'la raconte
Attention !
C'est mort c'est mort on est chaud
Un éléphant qui se balançait sur une toile toile toile toile d’araignée
C'était un jeu tellement tellement amusant que tout raconte
si on tue ... Quoi?
Oh la la attends c'est la bataille des Titans mon gars
Attention !
On va l'avoir On va l'avoir on va
Allez ça fait niquer Faut que je le tue (x2) vite vite vite . MAIS NON
Tu vois la la j'ai senti l’éléphant n'était pas avec nous la sur ce coup
Oh Putain
Ah c'est vrai j'ai pas de classement il devrait bien avoir de classement
Pour voir qui à la plus grosse
Oh lui faut que je le tue (x2) avant qu'il a une grande masse
Non . J'ai raté ma ♪ Channce ♪
Non mais ça c'est un petit peu ... le gars il a plus de portée
Viens vers moi hey Hugh Mungus
Faut rien faire . OH Putain Hugh Hugh je suis désolé je dois te trahir
OOOOOOOOOOOOHHHHHH
Oui donne moi donne moi ta masse
Oh la la la la l’équipe veulent me stopper il viennent de loin ils font tellement des choses biens
Je vais hâter de dire cette phrase ça fait 200 000 000 qu'on l'a dit
ET A CHAQUE FOIS C'EST LE MÊME RESULTAT
OH OH j'ai cru j'ai cru ohh c'est beau
Attends on pourra carrément monter dans un coup de poing avant ca je le connais on blague
Eh Bah voila on a zéro et on meurs
Oh super .
Moi = danger c'est vrai ? Pour de vrai
Bon je suis pas sûr je pense qu'il marche sur la marchandise
asdada asdada mon gars t'as pu en chasse "NOPE"
OH MAIS NON MAIS C'EST .....
EL PILOTATOR , ca veut dire le pilonneur en Espagnol
Tu ne parle en espagnol ça fait bien de dire ça
Tu sais pourquoi le plus honneur parce que la il s'en doute pour du petit téléphone mignon
Et sa toile d’araignée C'EST FINI !!
LA ON VA "PILONER" HEIN ?
OUI MARTOUPIKEUR Fils de pute
AH OUI OUI EL PILOL
Pulonneur
Qu'est ce que tu vas faaaire j'irai puter dans le milieu
Y'a un putain de boucheron
Dégage . Qui peut tuer Pulonneur
OH LA ON COMMENCE A AVOIR UNE SACREE MASSE MON GARS
OH PUTAIN CA C'EST DIT DE PULONNEUR CA
ALLEEZ BOOM
BOOM JE PRÉFÈRE ETRE PULONNEUR
HÉ LE PULONEUR EST PRESENT
ROPOPOPOP COMME DIRAI LES LIANAS
OOH
MON DIEU J'AI RENCONTRE UN AUTRE PULONNEUR
OH MON DIEU
OH PUTAIN PUTAIN IL MET EN PLEIN ESTA DEGAGE TOI
OH C'EST CE QU'ON APPELLE UN MONSTRE KILL
Ça pilonne ça pilonne
Ca ne s’arrête . QUI PEUT NOUS ARRETER ?
QUI PEUT REELEMENT STOP LE PILONNEUR DANS LE GAME
ECOUTEZ LES AMIS ON EST SUR NOTRE RONDE
TOUT LE MONDE A S'EST PIQUE DEVANT NOUS
LES AUTRES SONT EN TRAIN DE QUITTER LA GAME Y'A PLUS PERSONNE
OH LA LA J'ADORE C'EST FANTASTIQUE
CA ME PLAIT ÉNORMÉMENT CE QUI SE PASSE
IL S'EST MÊME PLUS DRÔLE LA J'AI TOUTE LA MASSE DU JEU LA
OH LA OH LA OH LA C'EST CHAUD LA C'EST CHAUD
IL FAUT SE CONCENTRER
NON AH JOSH EST LE GRAND GAGNANT
ALLEZ EL PILOTATOR IS BACK (EL PILOTATOR EST DE RETOUR EN ANGLAIS)
BITCH !
VOUS POUVEZ PAS EMPÊCHER UN ROI DE RETOURNER SUR SON TRONE
OP LA QU'EST CE QUE TU VAS FAIRE
REGARDE MOI REGARDE MOI EL PILOTATOR VOUS AVEZ VU CA
Y'A PAS DE PISTOLET VOUS AVEZ VU VOS PERES
IL SE FAIT TOUT SEUL . MERDE
OH PUTAIN SE RESSE EL MARTOTATOR L'ENEMIE JURE DE EL PILOTATOR
OH Y'A LE EL MARTOTATOR EST LA
C'EST LA BATTAILLE ENTRE LES DEUX RIVEAUX
MON DIEU !
OH OUI EL PILOTATOR
IL EST LA IL EST APESE DE LA FRANCE A GIO A RIO A GIO *RIRE*
RIEN NE PEUT EMPÊCHER UN ROI DE RECUPERER LE TRONE
PUIEZ POUR FARAGRA
EH C'EST EL MARTOTATOR MAIS A BOUT QU'IL VIENT EL MARTOTATOR
DEVRAS C'EST ELLE ...
BAH VOILA JOSH N'AIMAIT PAS CETTE BLAGUE
Eh bah la les gens c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur zlap.io
N’hésitez pas aller aimer si ça vous a plu
J'ai adore ce putain de jeu .io je le trouve genial
Tous ça trop cool de gérer ces mouvements
Mais j'ai reçu des mouvements de la masse dinercer il est assez bien fait
Donc c'est un truc un peu complexe et un peu ce qu'il est mignon rien
mais ce n'est pas un problème pour.... EL PILOTATOR
Merci d'avoir regardé a tous pour une prochaine vidéo partez vous bien et chio tout le monde
PEACE !!!!!!!
"Il y a des coins que j'ai pas compris désolé pour ça"